kinder in überfüllten flüchtlingslagern
politiker fordern schnelle hilfe für
unbegleitete minderjährige in
griechenland feuerhölle in australien
tausende kämpfen gegen die buschbrände
promi morrison entschuldigt sich für
seinen urlaub
jubel dass dabei der darts wm challenge
europe zieht als erste frau in die
dritte runde ein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg der vierte advent guten
abend und willkommen zu einem kurzen
nachrichtenüberblick rudi cerne ist auch
dabei für den sport hallo guten etwa
4000 kinder leben derzeit ohne eltern
oder andere begleitungen in den
flüchtlingslagern auf den griechischen
inseln
jetzt fordert auch grünen chef robert
habeck sie nach deutschland zu holen
das bundesinnenministerium aber lehnt
das ab obwohl sich schon einige
bundesländer bereit erklärt haben die
kinder aufzunehmen
seit wochen schon kommen wieder mehr und
mehr menschen über das mittelmeer von
der türkei zu den nahegelegenen
griechischen inseln das verschärft die
ohnehin schon katastrophalen zustände in
den lagern dort wie auf lesbos tobias
häfner berichtet es ist kalt es ist
matschig das flüchtlingscamp moria auf
der griechischen insel lesbos ist völlig
überfüllt und kein angenehmer ort
besonders die kinder und jugendlichen
leiden die sich ohne hilfe von
erwachsenen durchschlagen müssen viele
stammen aus syrien afghanistan
sie leben irgendwo in den olivenhainen
unter unzureichenden zeltplanen kein
vormund keine schule jemanden der sich
um sie kümmert
die probleme kennen auch politiker
überall in europa und haben sie
teilweise mit eigenen augen gesehen wie
niedersachsens innenminister pistorius
deutschland müsse minderjährige
aufnehmen meint er
die möglichkeit besteht die kapazitäten
sind da also finde ich sollten wir es
auch tun
da kann man dann auch mal herz zeigen
auch kurz vor weihnachten ein paar
kinder aus diesem elend rausholen
auch grünen-chef tarek will diesen
schritt lieber heute als morgen machen
notfalls auch als deutschen alleingang
weil die eu beim thema flüchtlinge so
gespalten ist
wir kennen die blockaden und irgendwann
bald weihnachten wenn wir in der kirche
sitzen und die kollekte wird
eingesammelt und ja sagt ich spende erst
wenn man nebenmann gespendet hat dann
was sind überhaupt nichts also
irgendeiner muss mal vorangehen
wesentlich zurückhaltender die union
hilfe vor ort gerne jahr gültige
asylregeln außer kraft setzen nein
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass ein
deutscher nationaler alleingang jetzt
ein falsches signal wäre weil er die
anderen eu-länder in die bequemen
situation bringen würde sich
zurücklehnen zu können
es bedarf aber eines gemeinsamen
europäischen ansatzes ähnliche appelle
auch von der menschenrechtsbeauftragten
der bundesregierung die neue eu
kommission muss schnell einen neuen
anlauf zu einer fairen verteilung der
geflüchteten unternehmen wünschenswert
wäre auch ein neues schutzprogramm für
unbegleitete minderjährige flüchtlinge
das kann aber dauern und so ist zwei
tage vor weihnachten nicht in sicht das
minderjährige nun schnell nach
deutschland ausreisen können jüdischen
gemeinden in deutschland eine lebendige
zukunft ermöglichen
mit diesem appell ist der gemeindetag
des zentralrats der juden in berlin zu
ende gegangen
zugleich gab es heute deutliche kritik
des antisemitismus beauftragten der
bundesregierung felix klein
beleidigungen gegen juden würden von der
justiz nicht konsequent genug verfolgt
das alles zu beginn des jüdischen
lichterfest chanukka hier am
brandenburger tor brennt seit heute
nachmittag am größten lokal leuchter
europas das erste licht hongkong kommt
nicht zur ruhe wieder gibt es proteste
diesmal für die muslimische minderheit
der uiguren
china wird von menschenrechtlern
vorgeworfen die uiguren massiv zu
unterdrücken
die polizei löste die zunächst
friedliche kundgebung auf nachdem
mehrere demonstranten offenbar versucht
hatten eine chinesische flagge zu
verbrennen
es kam zu auseinandersetzungen mehrere
menschen wurden festgenommen
in australien herrscht ausnahmezustand
bei einer rekordhitze von bis zu 46 grad
kämpfen feuerwehrleute seit wochen gegen
buschfeuer wie sie der kontinent noch
nicht erlebt hat zwei junge väter
starben bei ihrem einsatz
premierminister morrison hat nach
heftiger kritik mittlerweile seinem
hawaii urlaub abgebrochen und sich
entschuldigt anna maria schuck berichtet
sie kämpfen bis zur erschöpfung jeden
tag gegen das feuer gegen den wind und
die hitze tausende feuerwehrleute sind
im dauereinsatz es gott handy ist einer
von ihnen er und sein team haben schon
viele häuser gerettet und sich dabei
immer wieder selbst in gefahr gebracht
da ist eine aus unserem team von einem
auto angefahren worden und es ist echt
traurig aber glücklicherweise ist er
nicht schwer verletzt
sie bringen ihn jetzt ins krankenhaus
aber es ist echt beängstigend wenn sowas
passiert ihr gegner ist übermächtig
hunderte buschbrände verwüsten
australien seit wochen 25 tausend
quadratkilometer wald einfach abgebrannt
eine fläche größer als hessen mehr als
tausend häuser zerstört und australiens
premier taucht ab macht familien urlaub
auf hawaii
während zu hause der ausnahmezustand
herrscht dafür gab es viel kritik
jetzt hat der premier den urlaub
abgebrochen und sich entschuldigt und
auch beim thema klimawandel scheint er
der skeptiker plötzlich umzudenken
es gibt eine verbindung zwischen diesen
wetterereignissen den bränden und dem
klimawandel
wir müssen gegen den klimawandel
vorgehen und wir gehen gegen den
klimawandel vor scott handy nutzt diese
einsicht wenig er kämpft jetzt gegen die
flammen die jungs das haus für versucht
haben zu retten was steht
eine gute nachricht für heute das was
australien so dringend bräuchte nämlich
regen hat südeuropa derzeit im überfluss
mindestens zehn menschen kamen bisher
ums leben
portugal spanien frankreich und italien
sind von überschwemmungen und orkanböen
betroffen
glück hatte die besatzung dieses
frachtschiffs vor sardinien starke
wellen hatten es an die küste gedrückt
die zwölfköpfige crew konnte passen
schrauber gerettet jetzt du ja viel
wintersport gab es heute erneut ein
podiumsplatz dabei für vinzenz geiger in
der nordischen kombination
beim weltcup in ramsau fliegt und
springt der 22 jährige oberstdorfer auf
platz drei der norweger jahren magnus
rieber ist diesmal nicht zu schlagen
johannes hieber unterstreicht mit seinem
sechsten sieg im siebten rennen seine
ausnahmestellung in der nordischen
kombination
und wenn es ins geiger gelingt mit rang
drei ein weiterer podestplatz
olympiasieger eric frenzel springt
seiner bestform zunehmend entgegen und
wird nach rang vier gestern heute achter
im rennen versucht eine laufstarke
verfolgergruppe mit frenzel geiger und
triebe einzuholen doch der norweger hat
letztlich genügend kraftreserven um eine
nur noch sechs sekündigen abstand ins
ziel zu retten
rybak macht den norwegischen
doppelerfolg perfekt und meist kommt auf
rang sieben ins ziel
in guter verfassung präsentiert sich
karl geiger beim weltcup skispringen in
engelberg in der schweiz nach platz 3
gestern landet der 26 jährige heute auf
rang vier
damit zählt der team-weltmeister zu den
deutschen hoffnungsträgern bei der
vierschanzen tournee die in der nächsten
woche in oberstdorf beginnt im ersten
sonntagsspiel der fußball bundesliga
gewinnt fortuna düsseldorf ging union
berlin mit 2 zu 1 der erste erfolg nach
zuletzt sechs sieglosen spielen und
haben sie flick bleibt mindestens bis
zum saisonende trainer beim fc bayern
münchen ein verbleibt darüber hinaus sei
ausdrücklich eine gut vorstellbare
option heißt es zudem in einer
offiziellen vereinsmitteilung und
schalkes torwart alexander nübel
wechselt nach übereinstimmenden
medienberichten im kommenden sommer zu
den bayern
der 23 jährige soll einen
fünfjahresvertrag erhalten und in london
schreibt gerade eine 25 jährige
engländerin sportgeschichte fällen
sharrock sorgt bei der darts wm mit dem
zweiten sieg in diesem männersport für
die nächste sensation
3000 zuschauer im alexandra palace haben
einen neuen liebling fällen shamrock bei
ihrem zweitrundensieg beendet sie die
partie mit dem treffer ins bullseye für
den favorisierten gegner so judith aus
österreich bleibt nur die nebenrolle
wir können die männer schlagen ich habe
zwei hier weggeputzt es gibt so viele
tolle spielerinnen die berufstätige
mutter steht nun unter den 32 besten
spielern der welt
der deutsche max hopp ist in der dritten
runde raus nach 2 1 satzführung
unterliegt er dem litauer labahn oscars
in zwei zu vier sätzen
und jetzt feiert fällen schock erstmal
weihnachten mit ihrem fünfjährigen sohn
ja wie schön wenig weihnachtlich zeigt
sich allerdings das wetter es bleibt
meist stark bewölkt und vor allem im
westen und süden gibt es auch etwas
regen in den alpen oberhalb von etwa 900
meter schnee bei lebhaftem westwind vier
bis zehn grad und auch weihnachten wird
eher nass und windig der zweite feiertag
dann wieder freundlicher morgen begrüßt
sich hier christian sievers wir sagen
tschüss wünschen ihnen noch einen
friedlichen vierten advent